منطقه المحيط الهادئ باتت مسرح التنافس
الفعلي بين القوى الكبرى في مقدمه الصين
والولايات المتحده اذ تسعى بايجين لتعزيز
نفوذها وتسابق واشنطن الزمن لكبح ذلك الى
جانب الصين تقف روسيا ومعهما كوريا
الشماليه في تحدي القوه الامريكيه بينما
حلفاء الولايات المتحده هم اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه وتايوان وفي هذا السياق يقرا
الانسحاب الامريكي الذي كان سريعا ومفاجئا
من افغانستان فالبوصله الامريكيه اتجهت
شرقا لتعزيز العلاقات مع الحلفاء ومراقبه
نشاط بيجين عن كذب
بزياره رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
منذ ذلك الحين بدات الصين مناورات عسكريه
حول الجزيره وكثفت تحركاتها في المحيط
الهادئ وصولا الى ابحار حامله الطائرات
الصينيه اليومي باتجاه جزيره تيجوان اكبر
مركز للجيش الامريكي في المحيط
ذهبت الصين ابعد من ذلك بتنظيم مناورات
عسكريه مع روسيا حتى حلقت طائرتهما
الحربيه في اجواء بحر اليابان وبحر الصين
الشرقي تغذي هذه التحركات ومخاوف حلفاء
الولايات المتحده في المنطقه رغم انهم
ينخرطون ايضا في مناورات عسكريه مع القوات
الامريكيه
هذا العام ان اليابان اعلنت عقيده عسكريه
جديده لاول مره منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه شملت رفع ميزانيه الدفاع الى
اثنين في المئه من الناتج المحلي
والسبب حسب طوكيو وهو تنامي تهديدات الصين
وروسيا الى جانب كل هذا تتسابق الولايات
المتحده والصين الى تعزيز تعاقلهما مع
لجزر المحيط الهادئ وعقد اتفاقات امنيه
مشتركه معها بتقديم اغراءات اقتصاديه
للفوز بافضل يتم نفوذ
يوحي كل ذلك بان منطقه شرق اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ ستكون حاضره بقوه في المرحله
المقبله من خلال مساعي تشكيل نظام اقليمي
وعالمي جديد
[موسيقى]